7:15 and the Frankish Kingdom is
embroiled in a civil war it's quite
complicated but to summarize it was a
civil war not between men fighting for
the crown but for men fighting for the
title of mayor of the palace who was in
charge of the Kings household in Frankia
the King was basically a puppet to
whoever held this position and so people
wanted it there was supposed to be two
mayors one for Austrasia which was
hereditary and another for nutria there
was an attempt to merge both mayor
Alice's by giving them both to an
eight-year-old and revolt a man named
Charles Martel seize the opportunity
that the chaos brought her managed to
defeat his enemies in 718 Charles was
given the title Duke of the franks by
King Chilperic the second who again
didn't have any real power Chilperic
died in 720 and was replaced by Theodore
rich the fourth who Charles had
appointed Charles saw to increasing the
size of the kingdom and by 730 it had
expanded to this with Charles conquering
many of the german-speaking people's to
the east to the west and the south
though things weren't so rosy the Duchy
of Aquitaine had previously been part of
the Frankish Kingdom but had broken away
in the Civil War and was now having
trouble with their shared southern
neighbor this southern neighbor was the
Umayyad Caliphate which was at this
point the largest and wealthiest Empire
ever assembled the Caliphate after
numerous attempts has started to conquer
Aquitaine forcing its Duke Otto to ask
Charles for assistance he granted it in
return for Aquitaine submission and
Charles mobilised his army and met the
caliphates here at the famous Battle of
Tours sometimes called the Battle of
poitiers it was a decisive Frankish
victory and was thus cemented forever as
one of the most famous battles in
history the exact importance of the
battle is fiercely debated with opinions
ranging from it merely halting further
raiding to saving Christianity and
Western Europe anyway the Caliphate
would try again in the following years
but failed and my 740 ceased to be an
existential threat to Frankie er so in
737 King Theodore rich the fourth had
died and Charles decided he didn't need
to appoint another king and so he didn't
he didn't take the crown for himself
though and still ruled as mayor until
his death in 741 before his death the
territories of the kingdom had been
split between his sons carlomon and
Pippin in 743 they're both chosen new
King childress the third but as expected
he had no authority the first half a
decade of their joint rules or several
revolts in the east and some clashes in
the south but it was largely stable in
747 carlomon renounced his title and
became a monk leaving Pippin as the sole
ruler by 751 Pippin didn't really see
the point of childerik remaining on the
throne and so with the consent of Pope
Zachary got rid of him he proclaimed
himself King Pippin the third the fur
of the new Carolingian dynasty named
after his father Pippin was an
accomplished general and leader but not
as much as his father or his son and so
he isn't very well remembered he did
importantly begin the close relationship
between the Frankish Kings and the
Pope's Pippin lacked legitimacy which he
could gain from the Pope who in return
would gain Frankish protection from the
lombards Pippin aided Rome against the
lombard kingdom several times and carved
out these territories for the Pope to
govern personally the papal States
Pippin reigned until 768 when he died he
divided the kingdom between his two sons
Charlemagne the eldest and carlomon
Charlemagne's name comes from the Latin
careless Magnus meaning Charles the
great
so Charlemagne and his brother didn't
like each other but fortunately this
wouldn't be a problem for long since in
771 column and found himself slightly
dead as such Charlemagne gained the rest
of the kingdom beginning his
transformative sole rule Charlemagne's
first priority was war an expansion over
the course of his reign Charlemagne went
to war with pretty much everyone but the
reasons for these Wars weren't
exclusively territorial but also
religious to the northeast of the
kingdom of the Saxons who were pagans
and had raided the kingdom for centuries
in 772 Charlemagne noticed a raid to
destroy the sacred Saxon tree could aim
insel beginning decades of warfare and
forced conversions in the region 773 saw
conflict between the kingdom of the
Lombards and the Pope and Charlemagne
who wanted to maintain this prestigious
relationship between the Franks and the
papers he came to the Pope's aid it was
a quick war in the lombards were
defeated the next year when Charlemagne
captured its capital pavia he thereafter
proclaimed himself as the king of the
Lombards but did keep the territory
separate from Frankie a proper he also
conquered the Duchy of Spoleto and gave
some authority over it to the Pope the
war with the Saxons continued as a
grindingly slow pace until they rallied
behind a man could video Kent
Charlemagne was unhappy with this and so
in 782 he ordered the execution of over
4,000 Saxon prisoners and in 785 widok
and accepted baptism the decades
following this saw a major expansion of
the kingdom starting in 787 with the
subjugation of Benevento here the next
year the kingdom expanded further east
with the integration of bavaria and the
conquest of Carinthia which brought the
franks into contact with the very
wealthy Avars it wasn't long before war
broke out between the two and the franks
led by Charlemagne son Pippin invaded
the Ava's had lost by 796 in their royal
residents called the ring was sacked
immediately after this sha'lame
subjugated Croatia in these areas the
next year sha'lame finished subjugating
the Saxon so we could finally tick that
off in 799 he did the same to the
Breton's thus making
nicer to look at and he also conquered
Barcelona thus on the cusp of the Year
800 the kingdom looked like this and
it's no wonder that is sometimes
referred to as the Carolingian Empire
running this massive Kingdom required
ever more complex and capable methods of
administration the running of the
kingdom revolved around the royal court
which regularly moved around the Empire
to various royal palaces the most
notable being here at Aachen arkem was
not as is often believed the capital of
the kingdom but was an extremely
important city in terms of
administration and religious reform as
well as being Charlemagne's favored
residence the kingdom was divided into
counties and miss Attica which were
administrative districts they were often
inspected by Charlemagne's emissaries
called the Missy Dominica which is Latin
for n voice of the Lord the Lord in this
case being Charlemagne and not you know
God the Missy were made up of two
officials one ecclesiastical often a
bishop and one secular often account who
would make sure the Kings Authority
remained intact and would report back on
any potential issues the church was
extremely important to maintaining order
and running the kingdom bishops and
learners men of the church had very
prestigious positions at court and
Charlemagne who was a very pious man to
a great interest in church reform in
order to push through reforms
Charlemagne with issue capitularies
which were edicts enforcing changes to
church practices the most famous of
these capitularies was the admin ETO
generalís which basically dictated the
rules for the everyday lives of
Charlemagne subjects and standardized
Church practices it decreed that the
Christian nature of the kingdom was
immutable and that there was to be a
kingdom wide revival of learning which
we will get to in a minute the Year 800
saw the most famous event of
Charlemagne's reign when he went to Rome
after Pope Leo the 3rd had fled to him
because some of his enemies had tried to
blind him Charlemagne went back to Rome
with him to sort things out which he did
and whilst he was there Leo the 3rd
crowned him in pirata romanum or the
Roman Emperor Charlemagne thus became
the first emperor in the West since the
fall of Roma for 3 centuries prior this
title didn't really do much except grant
a bunch of prestige and wind up those in
they're still very much alive Eastern
Roman Empire the eastern empire often
called the Byzantine Empire was at this
point being run by a woman Irene who had
fallen out with the papacy and so
instead of patching things up they
simply picked a new Emperor the big
debate surrounding Charlemagne's
coronation hinges on whether or not he
was the first Holy Roman Emperor or if
it was also the first in 962 those
living at the time saw no difference
between the title bestowed on
Charlemagne or Otto the first and the
distinction exists in the mind of
historians only who like to categorize
things in fact the title Racine is no
different to the one bestowed on
Augustus so
previously stated Charlemagne wanted to
ensure that learning was revived in his
kingdom and so he oversaw a period known
as the Carolingian Renaissance the
reason for this much like Charlemagne's
conquests were religious since it was
believed that you couldn't be a good
Christian until you knew what a good
Christian was it was seen as the duty of
rulers to oversee the salvation of this
subject Souls and so the exercise of
power had to be combined with greater
knowledge a concept known as correct EO
from across Europe he sponsored scholars
to come to his court such as au kawin
from Northumbria pulled the Deacon from
the old lombard kingdom and Einhard
a frank ein Hart who was close to
Charlemagne wrote the life of Charles
the Great which is one of the major
sources about his reign schools were
founded across the kingdom the most
notable being Metz wasan and st. gall
and greater emphasis was given to
learning the curriculum was standardized
literacy rates amongst the nobility
improved in a new means of writing was
created Carolingian minuscule this would
see the implementation of many
grammatical conventions such as
introducing lowercase letters question
marks and standardizing letter forms all
of this led to a massive increase in the
number of texts produce and a
strengthening of the church whose
literacy rate made it indispensable to
leaders Charlemagne undertook much of
this learning himself and there is a
common belief that he was illiterate he
probably wasn't but there is an
overwhelming evidence either way he
didn't learn Latin which was an official
administrative language until his later
life there were nine hurt claim that he
could speak and read Greek but the truth
of that is less clear so now that
Charlemagne was an emperor who performed
his empire and conquered most of his
neighbors there was only one thing left
to do conquer more neighbors in 805
after some raiding Charlemagne took his
forces to these and subjugated all of
these people notably the Bohemians in
the south there were some more conflicts
with the Muslims and by a 12th the
franks had expanded to here the only
power in europe the catalan Charlamagne
now was the eastern roman empire which
held this territory most notably venice
in 812 Charlemagne won a diplomatic
victory when the Byzantines recognized
him as the legitimate Emperor in the
West which might have had something to
do with the fact that he had Nami just
outside of Venice whilst the size of the
Frankish Kingdom may have dissuaded
aggression by the Byzantines it didn't
deter the Danes pretty much immediately
after Frankie's borders had expanded to
reach Denmark's rating had begun up and
down the coast these raids were pretty
devastating but ultimately were nothing
compared to what Charlemagne successors
would have to endure Charlemagne's 47
year reign would come to an end when he
died in 814 his eldest son Pippin had
died in 811 and so he had only one
son left Louie better known as Louis the
pious his reign was somewhat less
successful than his father's though and
he ended up dividing the kingdom up
between his sons which led to the rise
of two major states in the West the
kingdom of France and in the east the
Holy Roman Empire
so Charlemagne is remembered as many
things a conqueror a patron of scholars
as a reformer and as a protector of the
church after his grandsons divided the
Empire between them Charlemagne was
considered the father figure of the new
States which came out of it much of his
reign was driven by his desire to be a
great Christian King he believed it was
his duty to subjugate the surrounding
areas and force conversions within them
in order to save the souls of those who
lived there it is important to remember
that much of his great legacy was built
upon the work of his forebears Pippin
and Charles Martel without whom there
may not have been a Frank here at all
one thing is almost universally agreed
upon though Charles most certainly
deserve to be remembered as the great I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching there are some book
recommendations in the description below
if you'd like to know more
you